hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain an american dystopian action
horror film called the purge spoilers
ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
at the beginning of the movie we see
several clips of people killing and
assaulting each other and houses being
burned
several shootouts and gang fights
resulting in hundreds of deaths are seen
in 2014 the republican and democratic
parties had collapsed in the u s
an economic crisis gave rise to a third
political party called the new founding
fathers of america nfa the party leader
is the u.s president bracken he and the
others from his party formulated an
extreme law called the purge
every once in a year one night for 12
hours straight all crimes are legal and
no emergency services will be available
people are allowed to release their
inhibitions in any way they choose
including murder it is now the year 2022
because of the purge the united states
has become virtually crime free and
unemployment rates have dropped to one
percent
it is the day of the purge
james sandon drives back to his home in
a wealthy gated community to be safe
during the night he sees his neighbors
place blue flowers in their front yard
to show their support to the purging
system
james too has a blue flower suggesting
that he is a supporter of the purge
james is planning to spend the night
locked in with his wife mary and their
children zoe and charlie
zoe is in her room with her boyfriend
henry
james is not fond of their relationship
so henry sneaks out of the house
as henry sneaks out the two see a
neighbor sharpening a weapon for tonight
as mary places the flowers in their yard
their obnoxious neighbor grace farron
approaches her with some cookies the two
talk about the lockdown happening in an
hour and go their separate ways
jane's son charlie is then seen playing
with his creepy robotic toy timmy
later that evening the family happily
has dinner together and goes to their
study room to prepare for the purge
first james turns on the surveillance
camera placed around the house
then he turns on the security system
which brings down metal doors and
windows closing every possible opening
in the house
lastly he brings out a gun from the safe
for protection then the family sits down
to watch the official initiation of the
purge on tv
it is announced that the purge is fully
in motion
weapons of class 4 or lower are now
legal
however all other weapons are restricted
government officials of ranking 10 or
above are immune to the purge so an
attack on them is still considered
illegal
after a siren blares any and all crimes
including murder will be legal for 12
continuous hours
police fire and any other emergency
medical services will be unavailable as
the broadcast completes the siren starts
to blare indicating that the purge has
now started
james tells his kids that since they can
afford protection they will be fine zoe
then goes back to her room
charlie on the other hand doesn't seem
to like the idea of the purge but james
tries to make him understand saying that
it allows people to take out their
frustration he too then goes to his room
zoe hears a thud in her room and finds
henry who had snuck in before the
security system was engaged henry tells
zoe that he wants to talk to her father
about their relationship
since james cannot throw him out of the
house during this time he thinks it's
the perfect time for him to convince her
father
everyone in the house relaxes while
charlie plays with his robot timmy he
moves timmy around the house surveilling
everything through timmy's camera
he sends timmy to the study room and
watches the surveillance footage he sees
a man running away from someone and
stand right in front of their house
charlie runs to watch the surveillance
footage from near and sees a man begging
for help outside their house
in order to help him charlie disarms the
metal door
at the same time henry makes his way
towards james room to talk to him
realizing that charlie has disarmed the
metal door james runs to the study room
and quickly puts the metal doors down
again
however the man gets in
james mary charlie and the man are in
the room when suddenly henry fires at
james from the stairs
he wants to kill james so he can be with
zoe
the two fire at each other and henry
gets shot
seeing this so he saves henry and takes
him away after which james looks around
to see that the strange man is gone too
to ensure his family's safety james
takes his family into a safe room and
goes to look for zoe he finds henry's
dead body in the room
we see that the stranger is standing
right behind him as he checks henry's
pulse but james doesn't see him
charlie sees a group of people
approaching their home through the
camera and calls his parents
the group is masked and has weapons in
their hands
the group leader stands right in front
of the camera and starts talking
he knows james's name and tells the
family that one of their targets was
lost
the group got to know from their
neighbor that the target had run into
their house
now the group wants the target out so
that they can kill him if the family
doesn't send him out in time they
threaten to get inside the house and
kill everyone as they know a way to
break in
then the group cuts off the power supply
to the house and everything goes black
james tells the family that they have to
find the man and force him outside but
charlie is reluctant to the idea
james and mary go out to search for him
charlie 2 looks for him with the help of
timmy and finds him hiding behind the
sofa in the living room he blinks
timmy's light at the man and makes him
follow it charlie is trying to help the
man
he takes him to his room where he has
formed hiding in the closet timmy
flashes his light at the hiding and the
man sees it he finally goes inside it
after thanking timmy
just then the purgers leader calls james
to the front door
the two talk through an opening and
james explains to him that they are not
trying to save the stranger the leader
then shoots one of his own men to
threaten james while claiming that the
group's equipment to break the door is
arriving soon
james fearing his family's safety gets
back to look for the stranger he goes
into charlie's room and sees the
stranger holding zoe at gunpoint
as he threatens james mary comes behind
him
james and the man get into a fight and
james accidentally shoots him he and
mary then tie the man to a chair
however the man starts to fight back
james makes mary pick on the stranger's
wound so he would give up charlie
watches all of this in horror they
prepare to give him to the gang but
realize that they would not be any
better if they did
the stranger too offers james that he
will go outside so that he can save his
family
james realizes how wrong they are and
tells mary that they will have to fight
back and defend themselves
just then the purges equipment to open
the doors and windows arrive
they attach huge chains to the doors and
pull on them finally breaking in
james hands charlie a gun and tells him
to hide in the basement he forgets to
untie the stranger in a hurry and gets
ready to fight
zoe hides in her room while the stranger
tries to free himself
now the purgers start to break in
one of them opens the main door for the
leader and he gets in with his gun
as they hide around the house one purger
gets in through the basement door and
attacks charlie as he is about to kill
him james shoots the man from behind the
group maniacally roams around the house
james fights and kills most of them but
the leader appears before him and stabs
him as james lays in the ground dying
the leader politely thanks him and
kisses his forehead the others start to
destroy everything in the house
charlie is in the study room looking at
the surveillance footage when he sees
two people approach the purgers in their
front yard and kill them he notices that
the people are their neighbors grace and
her husband
slowly all the neighbors gather to help
the sand ins but at the same time mary
is caught by two of the purgers the girl
perjure tickles mary as she begs for her
life
just when she is about to hit mary with
her machete their neighbor mr and mrs
halperson shoot the two dead
mary goes to help james but before they
can do anything the leader walks into
the room he clocks his gun and thanks
them for their sacrifice
zoe suddenly appears and shoots the man
dead before he can kill them the family
sits around james crying as he dies when
the neighbors arrive
mary thanks them for their help however
it turns out that the neighbors want to
kill the sandins themselves
they are jealous of james's money and
want to purge themselves of the jealousy
by killing the family they then drag
james's body to the other room and take
the others hostage
mary begs them to leave her kids and
they tie all three of them with duct
tape the neighbors then hold each
other's hand and thank the new founding
fathers for providing them with this
opportunity they have always been
jealous of sandon's perfect family and
when the purgers broke into the house
today they saw the opportunity as they
are about to harm the family the
stranger from earlier saves them he
shoots mr halverson dead and holds grace
at gunpoint the neighbors now stand in
the line in front of them
grace asks mary to kill them and put an
end to this however mary has had enough
of these killings
she tells everyone to stay there until
seven when the purge stops
a few minutes later everyone is sitting
at the dining table together in silence
the stranger still points his gun at the
neighbors to keep them in check
charlie and zoe cry while holding their
father's hand
suddenly grace tries to take the rifle
from mary's hand but mary breaks her
nose instead yelling at her
finally the sirens ring indicating that
the purge has completed
mary tells everyone to get out of her
house the stranger too leaves at the end
after mary thanks him for his help the
movie ends as the three surviving
members of the family look at several
dead bodies lying outside the house
a voice in the background narrates that
this was the most successful purge to
date other news reporters claim that the
streets of los angeles are filled with
dead bodies and the stock market has
risen to its highest
in the end a man says that he is no
longer proud to be american because both
of his sons died in the purge that was
my recap for the movie the purge
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching